oh nature hi I'm Garrett and I'm Nikki
we're fascinated by how other people
live so we're gonna try and find some
really interesting living situations and
live there experiencing a totally
different lifestyle to see which one's
bring us closer together
or push us further apart this week we're
living in a tree house it's over there
that one yeah
[Music]
I'm Dave and I'm Hollis we live just
outside of Sandy Oregon on the way to
Mount Hood we have 20 acres here and
this is our tree house which we started
building in 2010 and finished in 2015
look at it there it is so you built this
we did yeah that's amazing
I think one of the things about the tree
house is it gets us away from our own
health and our own life it just really
puts you in a very peaceful state to be
up amongst the trees Nicki and I are
about to go to live in a tree house
Nicki's kind of planted this tree house
she seems really excited it's in the
Pacific Northwest where she's from it's
gonna be cloudy rainy a little bit cold
I'm bringing all my sweaters for the
tree house we're gonna be investigating
two things one is it a good place to
live just on its own and to is it a
space that brings us closer together
or will push us further apart the tree
house is actually suspended so when
you're in the tree house if it moves a
little bit it's busted that's all good
it's like a little cabin that you've
elevated like you just sort of made it
harder for yourself it's definitely an
alternative lifestyle this is not gonna
be like in my apartment in LA come on in
[Music]
whenever we had an opportunity to use
products from the property we did so as
you lay in the bed the Timbers up above
you were actually milled from down trees
on our property so the floor is made out
of brown paper bags what and this is a
tree
the tree around the loft there's a cute
twin beds up there oh my gosh look at
that it looks so nice up here
if I were a kid this is where I would be
all the time I think the main challenge
we're going to experience is plumbing
because practically speaking I don't
know how that works so this is the light
switch for the bathroom but go ahead and
go in I think I ordered one already oh
my gosh the toilet is a composting
toilet so you don't stand up to use it
it's important that the liquids don't
get into the rear section so that's why
everybody says I'm kind of amazed that
you have a bathroom in a tree to begin
with yeah actually the perfect size it's
gonna be like the tiny house situation
again where Nikki and I are basically
forced to be staring at each other the
whole time especially if it's raining I
think that's it okay so come on in oh
wow that's more than just a fight it's
like a sauna or steam room we put some
towels out here for you guys so what you
do here is you press it in just slide
the switch down and you'll hear that
come on well I call it a magical
treehouse you could wake up in the
morning and look straight out at the
branches into the trees I envisioned
really building it for ourselves and for
our family and I think for me the
biggest surprise has been how much I've
enjoyed sharing it with other people
this place seems like a really ideal
place for me to live like I love the
climate I love the Northwest being
surrounded by trees and woods and land
is so peaceful and quiet
I'm afraid the treehouse is like
something that's pretty hip and cool but
actually it's very inconvenient and not
the best situation for roommates
oh so we're in the treehouse this is it
it's very cute it's very cozy it's so
dark
it's so dark like you just look out all
the windows and there's just nothingness
really cool that there's nothing
underneath us right now yeah that's
crazy
we're actually like floating between two
trees and like weak and I'm literally
rocking the house it's really funny
don't do that but it's very securely
this is not like a rinky-dink kids tree
house this is not like a project that
was built over a summer the bathrooms
probably the biggest source of anxiety
right now yeah it's very small so small
it's about the size of an airplane
bathroom and that's it I fit in here and
that's it it's just like a very long far
away sink cold huh yes but there is a
bathroom in here which I thought we
would have to go outside to use the
bathroom yeah it's so much better than
in our house all right that's like
that's kind of nice okay so that's so
this is our privacy partition yeah these
are like space booties I think by the
end of this you'll love it and youl love
Oregon because that's the sound of the
rain it's raining all night I was so
tired last night it's always slept in a
bit I think we're gonna make breakfast I
gotta put on a lot of clothes to go
outside right now cuz it's very cold and
rainy we're just gonna let that heat up
a little bit get the dry it off warm up
my hands I think he's still asleep so
you're like my only entertainment here
to talk to you I mean in theory this is
nice right Pleasant we're outdoors we're
grilling if I had to do this for
breakfast every morning I probably
wouldn't eat breakfast ever
but it's just like a lot of kind of
inconvenience nope see like it's just
not hot yet my nose is starting to run
it's just like not
looks sad because this won't get hot
this is gonna take forever there's such
a thing as slow cooked bacon that's what
I'm making oh good morning Barney I
can't get this pan hot enough isn't this
a burner I think it's just like a heater
I think it's just like keeps things like
what I think that might be a burner this
is a burner told you no [ __ ] luckily it
seems like the rain is dying and then we
gotta get stuffed and broil for dinner
you want a grill something for dinner
yeah House we're gonna eat dinner I
don't know I guess we have to you think
I don't like this because I don't like
being outdoors but it's the opposite I
like being outdoors but this is not
where you should be outdoors it's
soaking wet and cold
rumble Rumble YouTube showing off you
put another piece of bacon on there in
between the two oh you get this one this
is kind of nice us with our dogs sitting
by the fire as long as we keep figuring
out other stuffs into you not being so
concerned what we're gonna do just live
Cheers
there's Garrett on his way to shower
right there it's been a minute since we
had coffee and breakfast and I have to
poop no one else is in here right now
which I feel like is the proper time to
do it I was a little confused at how to
use the toilet but I think I figured up
it's very romantic that I left this
fireplace heater turned on water using
black switch
[Music]
made it look so easy yesterday ah there
we go and it's already pretty warm it's
infinite hot water so I can just guys
take my time I did it they didn't come
back yet easier than I thought
it's a composting toilet that's why it's
complicated so there's a toilet in the
shower so worse comes to worse I have to
go poop outside next time I'll shower
I'm going to do the pendulum swing okay
you're gonna help me there's a
two-person affair it's literally just
some toy that we that Dave built in the
woods it's so it's so hard okay ready
okay so it's dangerous oh hello are you
our tour guide Henry this is stuff that
like you could never do in like LA you
know the idea that you could own this
much land like that's incredible
ah so this is gonna happen go for it
[Music]
[Music]
the oh we have a dinner hey I'm so cozy
all right hot dogs
man it's chilly out here it's eat
anything that's already cooked so you
just gotta hate him up really did you
burn on reburning face can't see I don't
know nothing this kind of sucked it we
have to be outside in the freezing cold
just to make food all the time
a little bit but it was fun doing the
zipline Sunday it was outdoor stuff well
Cheers
[Music]
you're doing ghost stories no I don't
like those stories
so today after our activities we went
into town and I wasn't feeling super
well after and when we got back to the
treehouse I ended up like throwing up a
few times and / Garrett had to
essentially like watch and hear me just
barf into a bag Nikki's not feeling very
well
Makia I've lived together in like one
room before but never with one person
feeling sick trying to make her feel
better trying to make sure she's
drinking liquids actually today became
really fun eventually Nikki kind of
helped me get out of my comfort zone a
little bit once I accepted that it's wet
out and it's a little colder out then it
became a lot easier to have fun and like
I still went like swimming today
I started to actually see liking to live
in a tree house isn't really about the
tree house itself it's about all the
other things that come with it and I
couldn't understood that until I came
here and started living it so far I
think my relationship with Nikki has
improved a little bit but we'll see if
she thinks that tomorrow when hopefully
she's feeling better cuz she really was
looking forward to this
so hopefully that didn't drag her
experience down too much because she
approved my experience
how are you feeling Nikita better that's
good
sorry for throwing out there in front of
you I don't care we slept so late today
we simply 10 hours so dark up there so
dark I like waking up in the trees
alright we did we lived in a tree house
I had a lot of fun despite throwing up
several times last night when you signed
up to live in a tree house the number
one thing in your list is not
practicalities is it fun for a couple
days yes it's a lot of fun this is ring
situation by default did bring us closer
together because we like shared a tiny
loft together he totally like released
his inner child yesterday of like
running around the property doing the
zipline getting on the pendulum swing so
it was fun to see him like kind of drop
all sense of practicalities and just
kind of enjoy it yes
next week on home buddies our Reid
recreational vehicle this is probably
the most different living style we've
done I'm just really worried about a
poop situation happening Here I am I the
Grand Cayman there are too many
obstacles yeah it always feels great for
you who wants to be in control try not
to become defensive I think we're gonna
be at each other's throats
you